[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thanks, Eitan.
Finding high quality users
is the ultimate challenge
that all of you
face, so I'm here
to talk about how you can
find high quality users.
And specifically,
I wanted to provide
a lens of how Google thinks
about user acquisition products
across three specific lenses.
So let's get into it.
Simplicity with automation.
As you know, Google
has a variety
of placements where you
can put ads to find users,
so whether people are
discovering on Play, searching
on Google.com, engaging
with apps, surfing the web,
or watching videos on YouTube.
But historically,
what you have to do
is build a campaign for each
one of these properties.
Guess what?
We now have a product that you
can access all that inventory
in a simple set of three steps.
First just set you target
CPI, location, and budget.
Second, you put an app ID.
It downloads the app
icon and the images.
And third, if you have a
YouTube URL, you put it in,
and you have videos for
ads displayed across AdMob,
as well as YouTube.
And then you let the Google
machine learning take over.
Just with these
three simple steps,
you can get access to
all those properties.
So that's one way that
Google is solving for this.
Second is quality at scale.
Now, all of you know that
driving installs at scale
is critical.
But the new thing
is I want users
that provide lifetime value.
And it's basically
like bringing people
into your store who are
not interested in loss.
So this is what we
want to improve on.
So Conversion
Optimizer was a product
that was primarily used to
optimize installs at scale.
Now what we're doing is helping
you optimize buyers at scale.
What this means is
now you can get access
to acquiring users
who have either
made a purchase on Google
Play or paid for an app
or have a potential
to spend on an app.
And with a simple
click of a checkbox,
you can actually use
Conversion Optimizer
to find buyers like this
for your specific app.
And people who actually
did this at a global level
increased their
chances of finding
a buyer using this campaign 24
times than any other campaign.
So that's the second point
about quality of scale.
The third that I wanted
to talk about a little bit
is what only Google offers you.
So the first thing is video.
As you all know, YouTube is
a great platform for gamers.
So if you're not on
YouTube, please get on it.
And if you know, avid gamers
are about a third of the gamers.
And two out of the three avid
gamers visit YouTube daily.
And of these avid gamers,
almost two-thirds of them
download a game
once they see an ad.
So a great platform,
and ever since this
has been launched
at the end of 2014,
we've had huge success
for people to find gamers.
The second thing I'm
very, very excited
about is this format
called a Trial Run format.
In this way, prequalified
users who actually
will stay with you again.
This is an ad format
where you can actually
try your game in an
ad for 60 seconds
before you can decide
to download it.
It prequalifies users
in such a great way,
so you'll get users that
you actually want and are
interested in your game.
And the third, we typically
have optimized people who
are interested in app category.
That's one.
That was old news.
Number two, I shared, you
optimize for people who buy
or monetize better through
Conversion Optimizer.
But the third thing that
we want is engaged users.
Now you can actually
target people
who are active
gamers-- for example,
people who spend at least 30
minutes in the last 30 days
on games.
And again, this is all
achieved with a click
of a single, simple button.
So I know I rushed through this.
We're going to talk a lot more
about this in the round table,
so please make sure you
come and discuss whatever
you want to do to
leverage these products,
because at the
end of the day, we
want you guys to make
money out of your games.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]